sourou by jean bykov se dit prêt à
quitter le pouvoir
le président du kirghizstan l'a annoncé
ce vendredi dans un communiqué rendu
public sur son site internet
une proposition pour tenter d'enrayer le
mouvement de contestation dénonçant les
résultats des élections législatives
dimanche dernier je suis prêt à quitter
le poste de président de la république
kirghize
lorsque des autorités exécutives
légitime auront été approuvées et que
nous serons de retour sur la voie de la
légalité
la démission de l'actuel président
kirghize pourrait intervenir lorsqu'une
date pour de nouvelles élections sera
fixée et des changements effectués au
sein du gouvernement soro ii by jean
baeckeoffe n'est pas apparu en public
depuis l'inde y est assurée jusqu'ici
que sa démission n'était pas à l'ordre
du jour
précisant mener des négociations avec
différents groupes politiques c'est à
dire japarov l'un de ses principaux
opposants et nouveau premier ministre
nommé dans la confusion a salué cette
annonce
franchement j'ai appris d'un député que
sous rumba et jean bykov est prêt à
écrire une lettre de démission et
démissionner je suis d'accord avec ça
cette décision ne fera qu'aider à
stabiliser rapidement la situation dans
le pays
le président russe vladimir poutine
avait déclaré ce jeudi espérer une
résolution pacifique de la crise ce
petit pays d'asie centrale le plus
pluraliste mais aussi le plus instable
de la région a déjà connu deux
révolutions ai vu trois de ses
présidents emprisonnés ou exilés depuis
son indépendance en 1991